oh yes I am in a bathroom in a train
station in Connecticut hi guys and
welcome to Saturday hurry I'm keeping my
boys down in case someone walks in on me
in the bathroom but I thought this be
appropriate place to ensure this week's
video cuz this is a real piece of [ __ ]
week started out in Los Angeles Michelle
came to visit hello good afternoon it is
a quarter of to almost p.m. on Saturday
and Lucas here Michelle Vargas is here
so Vargas is here well no she's actually
not Michelle akin is here I can't but
your Aiken is here she also I don't
normally look like this on Saturdays
this is because windage ideas hair lady
extraordinaires here so this little girl
is here so it's total girls day yeah we
just opened some champagne because
that's so cool stew on Saturday and look
at all these hair products thank you big
sexy hair for sending me all of these
hair products those what they use on my
god I thought you were saying this is
what I use on my butt like how hairy is
your butt
then they went to a Golden Globes
after-party hello happy Sunday happy
Sunday
I just put glued fake nails to my hand
much glamour night I am going to a
Golden Globes after-party so I'm trying
to make myself into a person that goes
to a Golden Globes after-party this was
step one is it working she gets it
he's man
a steak chalupa and waffle taco oh sorry
I was joking then this happened
our backstage at @midnight yeah look at
all the glamour glamour glamour don't
steal my jokes after this episode there
glamour glamour this happened we were
dropping goose back off at doggy camp
because I'm going out of town for a
couple days and she she loves the car so
much it's crazy
she's conserving her energy now but she
just lost her mind
breakers
yeah you like the car it makes you so
excited makes you tired then something
else happened hello
it is Wednesday is Wednesday and Lindsey
Stirling is on her way over here if you
don't know who Lindsey Stirling is um
educate yourself because she is this
wonderful pixie violin player very human
that is just such a lovely person to be
around and she is coming over to shoot a
video I think we're gonna shoot a video
about relationship and dating advice
since we're a month out from Valentine's
Day and I think she'll probably have a
hilarious adorable perspective on that
the better thing that I encourage you if
you feel like you're living in a scum
Palace which is what I have been living
in for the past couple days to invite
people over who you don't necessarily
think have a full impression of you so
that it forces you to clean up your
whole place so that they think you are
so much cleaner than you are and that
you have you should together it's also
good because I'm headed out of town for
like ten days tomorrow adult tip so much
nicer to come home to a place that's way
cleaner than you thought it might be
smells like Lysol
that's better than human feces and or
mysterious dog feces isn't it's a hottie
Grayson to do anything I went to pee I
just peeing
it's happening
we're cute up I know you are wearing a
superkick I never got a chance to
mention that Lilly's here we just shot a
video and it was a really fun time it'll
be up on the channel in the near future
too late future no one knows and we have
human conversations about real things
yeah can you believe it I know okay so
get out of here so we can finish then I
took a plane to a train to Connecticut
to see an astrophysicist give a lecture
at a casino
over documentation or an idiot let's
come on on learning cabs and I'd like to
introduce to you our second son Neil
deGrasse Tyson but those books arm is
named they should really be called brain
failures because that's exactly what is
going on your body's atoms you'll see
them we descend one by one the senior
Larry will read them and you won't be
having fun that's my black hole Hulk now
today head to New York and then to
London for the UK book tour
make sure we didn't plan on coming to
one of the locations for the book tour
that you might be close to they're right
down there
take a look it's in a book reading my
bow I don't know
I'm getting out of here this time feel
we